Speaker 1: OK, today I want to start with
something a little different. We're going
to really do a deep dove into the architecture
and the genesis of right wing propaganda and
how an idea will be put forward with no evidence.
And then the fact that an opinion show has put it
forward then becomes the basis for more reporting
and more commentary. We've talked about this cycle
before. We're also going to look at how this one
in particular includes a complete reversal of the
burden of proof, where there will be an assertion
made by a right wing propagandist in this case,
Tucker Carlson. And then before you
know it, his position becomes OK. Well,
if you don't believe what I'm putting forward
without evidence, prove that I am wrong, which
is not how burden of proof works. OK, so let's
jump right into it. This is the sequence of the
positing that FBI agents were involved
in coordinated and participated in the
January six Trump riots. So we start with
the Tucker Carlson segment from last week
where he puts this forward. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: But strangely, some of the key people
who participated on January 6th have not been
charged. Look at the documents. The government
calls those people unindicted coconspirators. What
does that mean? Well, it means that in potentially
every single case, they were FBI operatives.
Speaker 1: OK, so the language is it means
potentially that they were all FBI officers.
There's no actual evidence of that. And there's
also all sorts of other reasons we went over
last week why someone might not be named in an
indictment and it could relate to the sequence
in which cases are being put together. It could
relate to protecting someone's identity for fear
of their safety. That the point is, Tucker says,
it's possible they're all FBI agents, but he's
provided no evidence that that's the case.
Speaker 2: Really in the Capitol
on January 6th, for example,
one of those unindicted coconspirators is someone
government documents identify only as person to,
according to those documents, person to state
in the same hotel room as a man called Thomas
Cauldwell and insurrectionist.
Speaker 1: So, again, no evidence
that persons, who is an FBI agent,
Speaker 2: a man alleged to be a member
of the group, the Oath Keepers person to also,
quote, stormed the barricades at the Capitol on
January 6th alongside Thomas Caldwell.
Speaker 1: So understand that first,
Tucker says, without evidence,
persons who may be an FBI agent,
and then he says persons who stormed the
Capitol, therefore, FBI agents stormed
the Capitol. But you've not proved the first part
Speaker 2: of the government's indictments further
indicate the KOBU, by the way, is the sixty
five year old man is dangerous. Insurrectionist
was led to believe there would be a, quote, quick
reaction force also participating on January 6th.
That quick reaction force, Caldwell was told,
would be led by someone called Person three
who had a hotel room and an accomplice with them.
But wait, here's the interesting thing. Person to
in person three were organizers of the riot.
Speaker 1: So, again, without evidence,
he says persons two and three could be FBI agents
and they stormed the Capitol and were organizers.
Therefore, the FBI organized the thing.
Speaker 2: The government knows who they are,
but the government has not charged
them. Why is that? You know why they
were almost certainly working for the FBI
Speaker 1: and then look at the language,
almost certainly. But he's presented
no evidence. There's no evidence.
Speaker 2: So FBI operatives were organizing the
attack on the Capitol, no evidence on January 6th,
according to government documents.
Speaker 1: That's not what the
government documents say. That's an interesting
transition. The documents just say persons two
and three were organizer's. He now says,
well, the documents say that they were
FBI agents. The documents don't say that.
Speaker 2: And those two are not alone in
all. Revolver news reported that there
are, quote, upwards of 20 unindicted
coconspirators in the oath keeper indictments.
Speaker 1: OK, so now that is the baseline.
This was the first crazy story last week
where we said, where is Tucker coming up
with the stuff? He's not citing any evidence.
He mentions revolver news. So the next day,
now that this is starting to get attention, he
brings on the guy who wrote the story for Revolver
News and pay attention to what that guy says now.
Speaker 2: Daryn Beatty heads up Revolver
News. We're glad to see him tonight. Daryn,
thanks so much for coming on. It sounds like,
according to this, I have to say, a remarkable
piece that you just put up late last night,
read it in bed at midnight that the FBI
was organizing the riots of January 6th.
Speaker 3: Well, yes, it certainly
suggests that possibility and I'm hearing from
Speaker 1: OK, you guys heard that, right? It's
Tucker brings on the guy who's his source, where
did Tucker get the idea that FBI agents organized
the Trump riots and stormed the Capitol? Well,
he says he got it from this article. He brings
on the guy who wrote it. And he says, well, it
certainly suggests that that is a possibility.
That is not evidence that this is the case,
Speaker 3: people, that this is the most important
and the darkest investigative
piece they've seen in years.
Speaker 1: That's another meaningless statement
he's hearing from people that this is a very dark
piece. So day one is Tucker putting forward
this idea. FBI agents stormed the Capitol
revolver wrote about it. He brings on the source
from Revolver and all that. The Revolver source
can say is it certainly suggests that that is
a possibility. We have still seen no evidence,
but now it's seen in the ecosystem. It's now a
runaway train. It's an endless feedback loop,
signal boost. So the next day, I mean, listen,
Tucker reported on it. I think it was Tuesday.
And then the revolver news guy went on and said,
oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. It certainly suggests it's
a possibility on Wednesday. So then on Thursday,
now we have Congressman Louie Gohmert on the floor
of the House saying we've got to investigate
the FBI's involvement in this entire thing.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: You know,
so if there were federal agents
that were involved on January
Speaker 1: four, which we have no evidence,
Speaker 3: we really need to know
what the FBI knew and when they knew it. And not
only that, we need to know how much participation
did any of our federal friends, either at
DOJ, FBI or any of the intel community,
what kind of role were they playing?
Speaker 1: Now, what's very so now the train has
left the station. You can't it's a runaway train.
But what's interesting is that we've been saying
since January 7th, hey, you know what?
There is a disproportionately high number of
off duty law enforcement that were involved in
this. There is an overrepresentation of current
and former members of the military that we need to
look at. These right wingers don't want to look at
that. They never wanted to look at that. But now
that they can without evidence, get on this Tucker
idea of it was the FBI, Tucker brings on a source.
The source says, well, I don't know, maybe it's
possible now. All of a sudden they're demanding
investigations and it's all based on nothing. This
is how they signal boost each other. Tucker does
an opinion piece and then it gets to the House on
the floor of the House in under 48 hours Tuesday
night to Thursday morning. Here's another example.
This is this sheriff, Sheriff Clarke. I mean, you
know, who really cares what he says? But again,
the point here is it very quickly becomes
the baseline for the commentaries they need.
Speaker 3: An outside commission does not have
the stomach to do this. They don't know how.
And they're afraid of what the FBI might have
on them, that they might leak. So you need an
outside congressional panel. My suggestion, for
example, would be that this is be headed by Ellen.
Speaker 1: OK, I mean, it's laughable that
Alan Dershowitz is going to run this panel, but
they were just voting against a commission
to investigate what happened on January 6th.
And we have lots of evidence and lots of reason to
think that that should be investigated. But now,
without evidence, the FBI did it, says Tucker,
and he's got no sources that actually say anything
definitive. Now, they want a panel and they
want Alan Dershowitz heading it up. So this is
how it works. It's all signal boosted on nothing.
It's built on nothing. And then as it continued,
Tucker Carlson eventually pulls a bait and
switch. Tucker knows he can't actually prove
any of this because there's no evidence for
it. He then flips it around and says, well,
prove us wrong if we're wrong, prove us
wrong, Tucker. That's not how burden of
proof works. But he doesn't care.
Speaker 2: Here we go. They became
hysterical when we mentioned that. You can't
say that they screamed. That's not allowed.
The geniuses at Twitter weighed in to inform us of
the people we had described as agents of the FBI
were, in fact, just FBI informants. So shut up.
Speaker 1: OK, now, if that's even true, that's a
completely different thing. The FBI regularly has
all sorts of bad people working as informants with
the promise or suggestion that maybe you'll
get less of a sentence or maybe whatever.
But if that's even true, those are not FBI agents.
And to suggest that makes absolutely no sense,
if that's even true, hilarious.
Speaker 2: But we won't shut up
and we shouldn't it could not be more obvious
at this point that the government. Is in fact,
hiding something, probably quite a few things,
so best to abandon theatrics and find out what
they are hiding. That's our job to many
in corporate media who claim that we are
spreading Russian disinformation. Instead,
please calmly answer these three questions.
First, how many of the so-called insurrectionists
on January 6th had a relationship with the FBI?
How many of these FBI moles encouraged others
that day to break the law at the Capitol?
We haven't heard anyone answer these
questions or even address them.
If the answer is none. If none of the
protesters were secretly working with
the FBI that day, then we were wrong.
Speaker 1: So we know that there was
at least one FBI informant that was there. But
that doesn't prove Tucker's case. That tells us
these were bad enough people who were on the radar
of the FBI that at least one was functioning as an
informant. It does nothing to prove Tucker's
case. And now he shifts the burden of proof.
Speaker 2: And we will apologize for it
sincerely. We'll admit it immediately.
But if the answer is not known and we're pretty
sure it isn't done, then people would claim
otherwise are liars and hacks and should leave
the public stage immediately because they have
betrayed their readers and viewers. Right to
if the Justice Department knew they're going
to be protesters massing at the Capitol
that day and it's clear they did know,
then why didn't they do anything to stop the riot?
Why didn't police at the Capitol allow protesters
to walk in as video shows that they did?
Speaker 1: Now, that's very deceptive. There
are moments when police recognizing they simply
don't have the numbers to hold back. Protesters
moved barriers, common crowd control. It's
been discussed ad nauseum here. The reason
that additional forces and troops and police
and officers were slow to get there was that
Donald Trump took hours to actually
make it happen. He had to be begged
in order to do it. And Tucker is not telling
you that because it doesn't help his narrative.
Speaker 2: That doesn't make sense. No, it does.
What's going on here? Why is no one asking that
question? We are third. And finally, why can't
we see the tape for ourselves? The government is
hiding more than 14000 hours of video surveillance
tape that shows exactly what did happen at the
Capitol that day. Why are they hiding that? And
why are news organizations demanding to see it?
You'd hate to think that NBC News, for example, or
Vox or The Atlantic or The Washington Post or The
Daily Beast or The New York Times or any of them.
Speaker 1: So this is also a red herring. I mean,
we have tens of thousands of hours of
what happened. I don't know how many
more hours we need to watch, but we have
endless hours and we watched it live
Speaker 2: or in fact, working to protect
the regime at the expense of the public.
But unfortunately, we are starting to
conclude that please prove us wrong
Speaker 1: and there it is. Please
prove us wrong. And of course,
when you present a case completely without any
evidence and then tell others to prove you wrong,
you are now completely in the paradigm of the
conspiracy theorists. This is similar to the lab
leak stuff, prove it wasn't a lab leak. And until
then, that's what we believe it was. Well, hold
on. Do you have any evidence to actually suggest
that? And so this is a classic bait and switch.
He presents the case without evidence. He brings
his source on who can only say it suggests the
possibility that this was the case. Louie Gohmert
and everybody else, Donald Jr. and everybody talks
about it. And then when pushed up against the
wall, Altucher can say is prove me wrong, prove
a negative, which is inherently difficult to do.
This is how it works. And you've got to be armed
to you have to be equipped with the tools
necessary to disarm it and to understand it.
Is this useful in understanding how this stuff
develops? Let me know. You can find me on Twitter.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is made
possible by none other than you through The David
Pakman Show membership program, you can sign up
at join Pakman Dotcom. A deep discussion coming on
today's bonus show, which is just for our
members about Joe Manchin and this Voting
Rights Act stuff. And I'm I'm getting increasingly
frustrated maybe is the word with what's going
on with this guy. But but we predicted it.
We predicted it. That story and many others
on today's bonus show, you can get instant
access by signing up at join Pakman dot com.